today I'm going to show you how I built
cyber Jeff a slack app that helps me
automate things that I would otherwise
have to do manually for members of our
slack channel if you're not already in
our slack you should join with a link in
the description it's a great way to
communicate and you can chat with me
personally along with a bunch of other
developers working on a similar stack if
you're already a pro member you should
be summoned by cyber Jeff he's a faster
and more reliable version of me when you
first join the slack Channel
he'll check to see if your email has a
matching account in the firestore
database with pro status if there's a
match he'll invite you to our Pro
Channel and tell you how to redeem a
sticker and t-shirt now this is a very
personalized slack app for my business
needs but in today's video I want to
show you how to build your own from
scratch if you're new here like and
subscribe and check out the full
write-up on fire ship IL now before you
start building a slack app you should
start by outlining your actual use case
because their API is absolutely massive
it allows you to automate things within
the workspace create chat BOTS
interactive UI elements and a whole
bunch of other things but if you're a
developer there are two main reasons you
would build a slack app in the first
place
companies already using slack may want
to enhance some sort of internal process
or communication flow that's essentially
what cyber chat is it's mostly an
automation tool but also serves as our
new AI overlord on slack the other
reason you might want to build a slack
app is to build a service to be consumed
by other slack users black has a public
directory for third-party apps all you
have to do is build something useful
marking it well and you'll have
enterprise clients throwing money at it
in no time let's go ahead and get
started you'll need two things for this
project you'll need some kind of slack
workspace that you have admin access to
and then we'll be using firebase as our
service back-end with cloud functions
but feel free to use whatever nodejs
back-end you prefer the first thing
we'll do is create a new slack app you
can do this from the slack API home page
and you'll see a big button there to
create a new app now like I said before
the API is massive so you kind of need
to know what you're building before you
get started some apps might want to
listen and react to events that happen
within the work space while others might
want to fetch or post information into
it like post new messages and things
like that or in our case a combination
of both
we want our server to listen to the
slack event of when a new users added to
a channel and then react to it by
posting a new message into the slack
workspace if you're not sure which API
you actually
I would highly recommend following this
flowchart provided by slack now getting
back to the slack admin panel let's
enable events events are essentially
outbound web hooks that allow you to
listen to events that happen within the
slack workspace or events triggered by a
bot in our case we only care about one
event which is the member joint channel
event we simply select that from the
drop-down and then you'll notice it's
asking us for a request URL this URL
will be an HTTP firebase cloud function
but before we can use it we need to
verify that we actually own it with
slack so you can see right now it's
currently unverified let's go ahead and
open up the S code and then we'll open a
terminal session and run firebase and
net functions I'll be using the
typescript flavor for this video to show
you some of the caveats there but feel
free to use vanilla JavaScript if you
prefer now let's go ahead and get our
endpoint verified all we need is an HTTP
cloud function this function will
receive a challenge parameter from the
request body sent by slack
we simply receive the challenge
parameter and then send it back as the
response now let's go back to the
terminal and run firebase deploy after a
minute or so that should deploy the
function and give us back our functions
URL go ahead and copy and paste that
value as the slack request URL you
should immediately get a green check
mark so now that the endpoint is
verified it's time to build something
useful we need to make sure that our app
is fully secure and there's a couple of
steps involved in that depending on the
types of api's that you plan on using
now back to the terminal for our cloud
function will install the slack web api
along with google cloud pub/sub and i'll
explain why that's needed in a few
minutes slack provides a big mono repo
with a bunch of different packages the
web api is used if you want to post
messages into slack or modify things in
the work space in order to use it in a
work space we need to authenticate it
with an OAuth token the token is unique
to the work space and not the app itself
so each workspace that has this app
installed will have a different auth
token since this is a private app
installed in a single workspace
we'll simply install it which will take
us directly to the OAuth tokens for the
team you'll want to copy this value and
then head over to the command line once
again and we'll set it up as an
environment variable in the cloud
functions environment by running
firebase functions config set
token equals roo token and that's the
only credential you need for the slack
web api but our app is also listening to
incoming events from slack so we need a
way to verify that those requests are
actually legitimate because it's
possible for a hacker to send fake
requests to our cloud function URL we
can prevent that by going to the basic
information page and grabbing our
sign-in secret we'll also use the
firebase functions config set command to
add this as an environment variable now
validating the signing secret from
scratch is kind of a pain so I actually
put together a dedicated snippet on fire
ship IO just for this purpose
slack has an events API package that can
do some of this for you automatically
but it doesn't really work well in a
service environment all we have to do is
perform timing save string comparison
using double hash message authentication
code which of course is something that
every programmer should know how to do
with their eyes closed you'll see a more
detailed description in the snippet but
basically we're taking our signing
secret and then comparing it to a
signature that slack provides in the
header if the final values match then we
know we have a ballot request otherwise
we reject it now let's get on with the
actual code implementation of the slack
app we'll go ahead and import the web
client from slack Web API then we'll
initialize the client using the slack
token that we saved to the functions
environment then we'll also instantiate
Google pub sup here so let me take a
second to explain why we need pub/sub if
you're not familiar with it it's a
service that allows you to pass messages
between different Google cloud services
so it's very similar to HTTP but it's
fully secure within the Google cloud
infrastructure
now the slack API requires that their
initial request is responded to within
3,000 milliseconds or three seconds if
you don't respond within that time
you'll get a timeout error and then
slack will try to retry that same
endpoint if your app has a long-running
back-end process like it makes API
requests to some other API then you'll
need to queue up some type of background
job to handle that work outside of the
3,000 millisecond limitation and that's
exactly what our pub/sub function will
do so that means the only
responsibilities of the HTTP function is
to verify the signature and then queue
up the background job we can do that by
stringify in the initial request body
converting it to a buffer then using the
pub sub client to publish to a specific
topic using that buffer
so essentially what this does is it
takes the request body and then passes
it off to a pub sub function that we can
handle in the next step and lastly make
sure to send a response to slack with a
200 status code so what we've done here
is passed off all the heavy lifting to a
pub sub function which has no time
limitation so feel free to take as long
as you want to handle it we can set up
the cloud function making sure to point
to the same topic that we publish to the
on publish callback will give us access
to the message which has the same data
contained in the original request body
the data that's available here depends
entirely on the type of event that
stripe has sent to your back-end you'll
need to mostly reference the stripe API
Docs because even though we're in
typescript it doesn't provide typing's
for the actual response data types
when a new user is added to a channel it
will give us an event which we can
access on the message JSON and then we
can grab the user and the channel from
that event so that gives us a user ID
and a channel ID from slack in this
implementation we only want to run the
code if the user is being added to the
general channel for the first time if
that's not the case we can throw an
error or just return null from the
function now the first thing we want to
do is take that user ID and grab the
full user profile which will contain the
email address and display name of that
user on slack we can do that by making a
request with bot users profile get that
will give us a Web API response and the
actual data we want is on the result
profile and that's an unknown type so
we'll go ahead and cast it to any so we
can destructor the properties on it now
before we go any further we'll need to
make sure that our bot has the proper
permission to read a user's profile you
can set up permissions or scopes for
your bot on the admin area for the slack
app you'll want to use the principle of
least privilege here and only grant
access to the actual operations that
your bot needs to do its job now that we
have the users email address we could
make a query to fire store to grab that
actual user record from the database but
I think we should just stick to the
slack API for this demo we'll go ahead
and invite that user to a new channel
then have the bot send them a direct
message with some text that welcomes
them to the new channel and that's
basically all there is to it
we now have a fast and secure server
olace back-end for building our slack
but there's a lot more we can do beyond
this simple use case if you want to
build a full-blown conversational bot
consider using something like dialogue
flow it makes it super easy to build
BOTS that have human-like conversations
similar to the Google assistant or Alexa
and you can add it to your slack channel
with just a few button clicks and if you
want to make the responses from the app
more interactive with buttons and images
and things like that
check out block kit it's a UI framework
specifically for slack I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and consider becoming a pro
member at fire ship IO you'll get access
to cyber Jeff who can only be used by
pro members but more importantly you'll
get access to a whole bunch of advanced
content thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]